this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you for the introduction and
the invitation to come I've never been
too ethica so I mean we're like the same
state we should have it's a very long
stage but all right so it's a life on
our planet has found ways to use roughly
1/3 of the elements that occur naturally
on our earth and of these elements my
research focus is mainly on the first
row transition metals and think and
what's really fascinating about these
elements that provide nearly universal
essential functional capabilities to
enzymes and proteins usually they're
needed and trace amounts but there's
some really fundamental functions that
need these elements I mean what would we
do without transcription translation
respiration photosynthesis all of these
processes and many many more require one
or more transition metals to function
and then what's really fascinating about
these elements is if they're allowed to
over accumulate in the cell it can
actually be highly cytotoxic and so
because of this dichotomy between we
need these elements or essential
nutrients but if they're allowed to over
accumulate they become toxic the
abundance and veil ability of these ions
and the cells are really tightly
regulated and organisms can be
negatively impacted by both limitation
there's not enough of these nutrients
you die and they can be negatively
impacted by excess if there's too many
of these metals you die and but most of
us in this room we're not thinking hey
that I get enough zinc in my diet today
that they get enough iron and that's
because it really it's only when we see
mutation and these homeostatic
mechanisms that we see oh how important
these nutrients are and so a single
point mutation in a metal transporter
for instance can be really quite
detrimental and so metal homeostasis
describes those strategies that evolved
to ensure that supply of these metal
nutrients meets demand but you have to
remember that this is a bit complicated
because of the both supply of these
nutrients and also the demand for these
nutrients can actually change and
there's some challenges so one is that
most metalloproteins
not all the TEL approaches but most
metallic proteins needs
find the right metal my favorite example
of this is photosynthesis electron
transfer and so what we see here is that
the midpoint potential for these
different metal cofactors varies over a
volts and that's because there's a
really intimate interaction between the
actual protein the particular cofactor
porphyrin ring iron sulfur cluster and
then the metal and so here for instance
we got four iron four sulfur two iron
two sulfur teams copper manganese and
really quite a breadth of potentials
another great example here is class 2
sign in and cytochrome C 6 these are two
soluble proteins that transfer electrons
between the cytochrome b6f complex and
PS 1 these proteins are completely
different proteins they don't have any
sequence of molarity they do the exact
same reaction they have the exact same
midpoint potential one uses copper and
one uses heme to do that now the other
challenge is that actually selectivity
is not very precise and this could
potentially lead to miss modulation so
you have these proteins they need the
right metal but it's not that
straightforward
um this is the Urban William series
that's been described fifties and really
what we see in chemistry is that all
things being equal if we look at these
divalent metal ions the generally
regardless of the metallic protein
copper is gonna bind with the highest
affinity or the highest ability followed
by nickel cobalt iron manganese at the
same time a lot of these metals wither
if they're free like if they're allowed
just to float around in the cell they
can be toxic
so the metals that can actually transfer
electrons can participate infants in
infants in light chemistry and this can
create oxidative stress which can be
very damaging and then metals like zinc
and copper can bind non-specifically to
proteins and lead to protein
precipitation so the main question in my
group is how do cells transport in
traffic these ions to ensure proper
metalloprotein biogenesis
while avoiding toxicity and how I do
that
is that my group we integrate a lot of
genomics and post genomic data also
mining high-throughput experimental data
to generate hypotheses about gene and
protein function and then we actually go
to the bench and test that um and so to
illustrate this approach I wanted to go
through three separate vignettes that
published and that I'm currently working
on so the first is a copper chaperon for
the chloroplast
alright so copper so copper is kind of
at the top of this urban William series
and so it's thought that coppers is the
cell is really careful about copper and
that once it's imported into the cell we
think that there's actually these small
soluble copper chaperones
in some cases we think they actually
made off with the copper transporter and
deliver copper to where it needs to go
and eukaryotes one of those is this
copper ATPase that's in the Transvaal
gene and it's thought that this copper
shock brown actually docks with this
cute helix and so what this allows is
direct lie against the ligand transfer
copper so copper is never free it's
always bound onto a protein alright so
I'm interested in plants green algae
plants you name it and so one of the
questions I was interested in as a
postdoc as well how is copper traffic to
the chloroplasts so in the chloroplasts
of plants we have this class design in
protein and this protein actually gets
transported as a nation polypeptide
across the envelope and then the
thylakoid membrane of the chloroplast
once it's in the lumen it folds then it
binds copper and copper is is the
essential cofactor for the electron
transfer so that means that copper has
to once it gets into the cell has to
cross the envelope the stroma all the
way down for maturation a plasti Cynon
and some years ago the group of marina's
peel on actually found that there's two
copper ATP ASE's these are the same
family of the ATP ASE's we find in the
Golgi and they pop pump copper across
the inner envelope and the thylakoid
membrane for maturation of plastic
but the big question was well what about
a copper chakra if you're ever gonna
need accomplished chakra and the
chloroplast is the place where you're
going to need a cup of chakra because
the chloroplast is actually making
oxygen copper and oxygen do not mix
creates very dangerous reaction oxygen
species so what about a copper chaperone
so the first place is to start with the
obvious so the obvious would be to look
for homologs of known copper chaperones
and you can apply a bit of logic and
some rules so that a copper a missing
chloroplasts copper chaperone should
only be found in genomes with a core
class that has pasta Simon we think that
they should interact with ATPase so the
ATP ASE's k1 in case you should be there
and then it should be conserved in all
of those genomes and this is basically
just the green algal genomes and so this
is a protein similarity Network each of
these dots here is a protein the lines
connecting them is sequence similarity
between those proteins and what you see
here is that there's actually been a
really large expansion of these copper
chaperones in land plants so which one
is the copper chaperone well if we
include Chlamydomonas which is a green
alga in this analysis there's only one
copper chaperone here and this is
probably the copper chaperone for the
trans-golgi it's a note in copper
chaperone so this isn't really a good
bio formatic I'm hit for what's the
missing chakra so if the obvious isn't
that obvious what about something that's
not so obvious and this is what I found
this is looking at the gene for PA a1
which is the copper ATPase and the inner
envelope and what I saw is that this
gene actually has an alternative
splicing event that produces two
transcripts the first transcript this
long transcript encodes the full-length
copper ATPase and this second transcript
produces just the in terminal metal
binding domain of the copper ATPase
as soon as I saw this I said aha this is
interesting because I knew already that
the true soluble copper chaperones the
intermodal metal binding domain of the
ATP ASE's this domain of the copper
chaperones are all structural homologs
of each other so a simple hypothesis is
is this the missing copper chaperone for
the chloroplasts so in order for that to
be the case remember I had these rules
it should be here not here and so at
first I was like well this is an
alternative splicing a bit are alternate
splicing events really that conserved
across changes and the answer is in this
case yes so here I'm looking at this is
chlamydomonas Ryan hardy I this is the
single cell green alga these are various
land plants um the evolution here is at
least 750 million years these guys have
been diverging and in every single case
I found evidence of a long transcript
that's just the concrete EPA's in a
short transcript that's just that in
terminal metal binding to me when I was
doing this analysis I was really
frustrated because there were some land
plant some genomes I just could not find
evidence of alternative splicing and so
I was really frustrated until I figured
out that in a lot of genomes there's
actually been a duplication event of
this gene and sub functionalisation
we're now one locus has the full-length
copper ATPase and the other locus just
has this short in terminal metal binding
domain and then what's interesting is
that we've kind of captured a snapshot
where there's been independent
duplication events leading a
sub-function ization and then here in
the grasses there's actually been the
duplication event was in an ancestor and
now you have two genes one for the metal
binding domain and one for the copper 88
alright so let's test it so we did a
couple of different experiments and this
is looking at copper transfer between
this internal metal binding domain and
the transporter ATPase and what we do in
this experiment is we load the putative
chaperone with copper we mix
with the transporter we then reap yura
fie the transporter and asked as the
copper collude with the transporter
which would happen if there's been
transfer from the chaperon to the
transporter and so here we're looking at
the putative copper chaperone with PA a1
which is the transporter that shares the
gene with and a lot of genomes and sure
enough we see Co Ellucian between the
transporter and copper suggesting that
we did see transfer we can do the same
experiment with PA a2 which is second
ATPase in the core class and we see no
evidence of transfer so it looks like
it's specific to P a1 not P a2
the next thing we can do is we can
actually so both of these ATP ASE's have
their own metal binding today there's no
evidence at the second ATP ASPA to is
there's no evidence that it's internal
metal binding domain ever exists is free
standalone protein but we can clone it
as a standalone protein and repeat these
assays and what we see with that is that
for either P a1 or PA 2 we see no
transfer so it looks like this is
specific between PA 1 and PA ones metal
binding domain these transporters are
copper stimulated ATP ASE's they're
ATPase ATP dependent pumps so we can
also look at ATPase activity to test
this interaction so here are the two
purified proteins or we're just you know
providing free copper and measuring the
ATPase activity and then we can also
provide copper already bound to the
putative copper shock Road and so we see
stimulation of ATPase activity for PA 1
not K 2 and then we can do the same
thing with this internal metal binding
domain of PA 2 and we see no stimulation
of ATPase activity for either
transporter alright so in a nutshell
that's what I love to do I love to look
at comparative genomics think about gene
and protein function contextualize it
with evolutionary principles come up
with a hypothesis and test it I put
these arrows here
because often when we get to the [ __ ]
the hypothesis is either wrong or maybe
there's something different going on one
thing I'm not going to go through but an
example of this is with this story that
we actually found that this transporter
is actually flipped in the membrane
versus how it is in bacteria all right
so let's move on to heme so iron so I am
very important in adequate access to
iron chronically limits photosynthesis
both on land and also in the oceans and
so some years ago we found out that in
some places in the ocean it's actually
iron that's limiting for phytoplankton
growth not nitrogen so you'd usually
expect it's also predicted that 30% of
arable lands this is our farmland is
actually considered iron limited and
then actually iron deficiency is the
most common and widespread nutritional
disorder in the world in particular
populations children pregnant women are
particularly sensitive iron deficiency
so iron is probably one of those
micronutrients that some of us at
certain points in our life really do
need to think are we getting enough iron
in our diets so I've been really
interested in this question which is how
is iron traffic to the core class as you
can see here the electron transport
chain is really highly rich in iron
needs a lot of money and so one place to
look is to look at fadjen egg
inventories and what this basically
means that you can generate lists of
protein families that are only found in
particular genomes from organisms with a
specific phenotype trait you name it
whatever and so in this case I was
interested in gene families that are
only found in plants and green algae so
only found in those organisms that have
photosynthesis but also in the green
lineage and so these are some lists that
have been around for a long time these
are called the green cut unless
and so these are inventories of proteins
are only found in eukaryotes with color
class from the green lineage and perhaps
surprising although these are kind of
like those genes and proteins that make
a plant plant
there's about 550 of these that we don't
know what they do it either has an
unknown function or the function that's
been annotated is vague and who really
knows so one of the projects I'm
collaborating with a big consortium of
people is to take lists like this DNA
synthesis has gotten pretty cheap these
days we're collaborating with jgi to
synthesize and assemble these into
vectors I have a collaboration with
Steve Almo and Einstein to do small
expression screens to see if we can
actually have protein to work with and
then once we decide we have protein we
can work with I do what I do with
compared to follow genomics and judgment
hypotheses and then we go in and test it
and so one of the proteins that I wanted
to talk about today is this protein so
the screen alga Chlamydomonas it's
annotated as PPO 3 so it's actually been
given a name even though we don't know
what it does its annotated as this
paradox I mean five prime phosphate
oxidase like in a rabbit OPS's this
ortho ortholog of the Chlamydomonas
protein is annotated as FM in binding
which is a very specific and very vague
annotation at the same time 5 is ohm
which is my go-to database for plant
genomes
it's annotated like this this basically
just means it has similarity to a
panther domain so C reg protein okay
again not too useful all right
so warning about functional annotations
1 the functional annotation is or could
be wrong ok the annotation could be
inaccurate misleading and complete vague
ok rule number two you need to know
where the annotation came from if you
care ok and what that means is you need
to actually understand which protein was
actually experimentally characterized to
have that functional annotation
and then the last rule is again if you
care which I care you need to know how
your protein subfamily or family of
proteins is actually related to that
characterized protein all right so where
did these annotations come from now it
can actually be sometimes impossible to
figure out where a functional annotation
come from in this case we can do a
phylogenetic reconstruction of this
super family so this clade down here is
the protein I'm interested in this PPO 3
up here this is the clade all these
stars are proteins that have been
experimentally characterized to have
this function pyridoxamine five prime
phosphate oxidase these are proteins
from rabbit OPS's human drosophila ecoli
sacrum icees so these are the true
pyridoxamine five prime phosphate ox
basis
c reg this one here this is again an
independent clag clade this is the
Syriac protein that's been characterized
in human down here is my PPO 3 it's
actually more similar to this protein
here called blue t rbp which is a heme
binding protein that regulates glutamate
trna reductase which is the first enzyme
and tetra pyro biosynthesis and it's
this protein family is more similar to
that protein than it is to the paradox
needs the hand here's something else is
you can look at the domain architecture
of these proteins and so here they all
have this split barrel domain here in
blue sole family glooty rbp and my PPO 3
protein actually have a second domain
that these proteins don't have a Duff
which stands for domain abundant
function if we take a closer look at
these domains so the first so this
barrel domain family it's called the f-m
in binding split barrel domain super
family so now we know where that Arab
adopts this annotation
FMN binding came from this is looking at
the whole super family it's a huge super
family each of the nodes which you can't
see actually represent more than one
protein
this little tiny clade right here
cluster these are the true pn p OS down
here we have these c right proteins that
are really only found in human animals
and plants and then this cluster down
here is this tetra power biosynthesis of
protein binding protein and the protein
I'm interested in PPO 3 we can zoom in
this is looking at those proteins in
this cluster that have the stuff domain
and then something that was interesting
when I looked at the superfamily is that
there's actually another cluster of
proteins over here huggsy that also has
the stuff so the same architecture
domain architecture if we look at just
the Duff so these are all the proteins
that have the stuff domain here so here
what's nice is that yes PPO 3 is similar
to this binding protein but you can see
that it's actually way more similar to a
lot of bacterial proteins so these are
Proteobacteria proteins these are
actually bacterial proteins here down
here is this huggsy on something else is
interesting is although this huggsy
which is actually a bacterial protein
that's been implicated in he need a
gradation and he utilization its domains
are actually swapped
versus the glute ER BP which again a
heme binding protein within this duff
family we also find proteins that look
like their heme oxygenase --is so we
have this diffuse to what looks like a
heme oxygenase domain so simple
hypothesis here is is the stuff a heme
binding domain well we can test that so
we purified the protein from the screen
alga Chlamydomonas which has the two
domains
we also purified a protein from
cyanobacteria that only contains the
Dufty me this stuff
and what we can see is that in vitro
this is a classic shift the soroban here
that if proteins bind he music a pretty
characteristic shift
not so prominent with PPO 3 the sign
about your protein you can see it quite
clearly here but of course seeing is
believing and we are actually able to
get some structures so this is the
structure of this duff protein from
Seneca Cistus as purified and what we
were surprised to see is actually the
ask purified form bind zinc and has a
pretty you know traditional zinc site
here a tetra coordinate Z now whether it
actually binds zinc or not is a whole
physiologically huge question but looks
like it binds metals or something I can
confidently say what was really
interesting is when we added human to
the crystallization buffer and what we
found is that the dimers rearrange and
we get the craziest heme binding site
I've ever seen that anyone has ever seen
where we actually have two zinc sites we
have a doubly deprotonated histidine
that's actually a bridging the zinc and
the iron and the heme so it's kind of
like a tri nuclear metal site right now
I've contacted people who are supposed
to be the top and the hand field and
they've never seen anything like this so
it's interesting I have no idea what it
does however it's not completely
unprecedented in copper zinc s OD we see
a doubly deprotonated histidine that
bridges the competency so having a
doubly deprotonated histidine isn't too
crazy also there's a heme transporter in
bacteria that has the iron as the iron
and he ms coordinated by 2 histidines
and it's thought to protect the heme
during transport we also see this form
and hit the HeLa chrome state of
hemoglobin and we also see this in the
hexa coordinate hemoglobins the issue is
though is that in the hexa coordinate
hemoglobins ii histidine is the binding
is reversible
but you know those hexa coordinate him
aglow means they don't have these
additional metal sites so the question
is why
are these zinc sites actually what I can
tell you so we don't know so you know
I'll have to leave it there but what I
can tell you is that this this metal
binding site we really only see it in
the sign of bacterial proteins however
it's absolutely conserved and all the
sign of bacterial proteins outside a
sign of bacteria basically half of this
metal sites conserved and then but it
does look like that when we've had
fusion with this oxidase like domain
this split barrel domain like we see in
plants and like we see in the heme
degradation protein huggsy
it's coincident with loss of this of the
scheme site so the summary for this part
is that we found a new zeke iron he come
try a nuclear site we we couldn't have
predicted this from the sequence and we
are working on answering some questions
one is the these metal sites involved in
binding the most important question is
this structure even physiologically
relevant does this Zeki zinc site form
in the cell and then we still don't know
what the function of this protein is
alright so the last story real quick is
a universal metal transfer that has been
my on and off obsession for some time
alright so zinc zinc very important zinc
is involved in regulating transcription
trying you know RNA polymerase carbonic
anhydrase is the ribosome protein
synthesis copper zinc SAT lots of
proteins need zinc support for immunity
various neurological diseases disorders
have been linked to zinc by vascular
disease fertility intestinal health you
name it
zinc has been implicated so there's all
these important zinc proteins well how
are they actually loaded with zinc as
far as we know we have a pretty good
understanding of how zinc is transported
across the membrane and then enters a
black box which we call the labile Z
which is basically just anything
it's probably some cysteine-rich
proteins metabolites free amino acids
you name it who knows and then magically
proteins become loaded with C and maybe
that works as a model that's fine but
what about under zinc limitation what if
there isn't enough zinc to go around to
all these essential proteins um does
life have a way to actually prioritize
that zinc so that the essential zinc
proteins get seen
but the non-essential zinc proteins we
say we don't care about you you don't
get seen and this is the screen alga
Chlamydomonas which has been a really
great model system for looking at metal
limitation and so this is looking at RNA
seek from various types of nutrient
limitations zrt one here is a known zinc
transporter and there's these two genes
they see p1 z c p2 that are really only
expressed under zinc limitation what's
interesting is that in bacteria and in
humans homologs are also induced by z
deficiency pretty much they all have
unknown function um and and eukaryotes
and really bacteria they're typically
annotated as kabbalah and biosynthesis
proteins which in eukaryotes doesn't
make a lot of sense because eukaryotes
cannot make a bologna de novo so what
are these proteins doing so this is the
family so here i'm looking at this the p
fam that detects these called w like
proteins it's a pretty big family
there's over 40,000 members archaea
bacteria eukaryotes they're all over the
place
what's interesting right off the bat is
that these proteins are related to URI G
and height B which are known gtp
dependent proteins that are involved in
metallo Center biosynthesis of urease
and nickel-iron hydrogenase I'm just
orient you the two Chlamydomonas
proteins one is found in this cluster
and then the other one is found in this
cluster if we look at the sequence
similarity of these proteins they have
some very uncharacteristic to
pas motifs and so it looks like for the
most part this activity GT pas and then
also metal binding the cysteine-rich but
youth is conserved and so I hypothesis
really based on similarity to your eg
and height B is that these are gtp
dependent metal transfer aces involved
in the telecentre biosynthesis for the
ones on that look like they're induced
only under zinc limitation it must be a
function that perhaps becomes essential
during zinc limitation so maybe they're
needed for delivering zinc or another
metal to zinc dependent protein during
the implementation now but to test this
hypothesis we need a client protein now
the tricky thing with this family is
that it's a really large protein family
there's multiple distinct clusters some
organisms like my favorite green alga
Chlamydomonas have many homologs there's
more than ten of these proteins and then
individual proteins from various
bacteria have been linked to different
functions so down here we have the
proteins that were first characterized
to be involved and COBOL and by
synthesis back in the 90s these are the
true Cobb W proteins we also have a
protein up here in ha3 that's an iron
type nitrile hydratase activation
protein and then up here we have John
Hellmann's recently characterized zag
eight well it's not recently
characterized but the real like big
discovery for this protein happened
recently zag a which it looks like it's
actually as ATPase
and a zinc chaperone for this protein
full e I've been really interested in
what's the function of these proteins in
eukaryotes so this cluster up here
contains the homologs and human yeasts
and plans if we take a closer look at
the specific cluster so here is a
phylogenetic tree looking at this
cluster and what we see here is that
there's one clade here so these are all
orthologs that are found in eukaryotes
and they're typically only found in the
single copy and so one assumption is
that likely these
birth logs all share the same function
and maybe they all have the same client
protein so this is the protein that they
deliver metal to so one thing we can do
is there's a lot of high-throughput
protein-protein interaction data is out
there especially for these organisms so
this is yeast yeast sacrifices
cerevisiae schizosaccharomyces and then
also human but what you can see here in
here these are all the these cub W like
proteins which I'm kind GM c1 and these
are all the interactions that have been
found in these high throughput studies
but the question is well one of these
interactions is actually biologically
significant to my question at hand a lot
of these interactions could be
experimental artifacts
it could be interactions that are
important for regulation I'm looking for
a very specific interaction so I looked
at what protein protein interactions are
conserved across all of these very
different organisms and there's actually
only one
this is Matheny tamina peptidase type 1
it's a by nuclear metal binding protein
just like urease which is the target for
URI G it has an essential function and
it's thought to be a zinc dependent
protein but again I wasn't convinced
it's like it's high-throughput data you
know is it valid is it not I like to
look at the evidence so if we look at
the evidence we see okay there's a used
to hybrid experiment and sacrum I sees
another used to high Ruda case gets a
secre my sees in humans there was a
completely different type of experiment
this is affinity capture ms and there
were at least let's see three different
studies that found this interaction okay
what was also interesting is that
there's two classes of these methionine
you know pep spacing eukaryote it's a
type 1a type 2 the interaction was
always with the type 1 well what really
sealed the deal for me was this there
was a high-throughput genetic
interaction study in psycho my sister
BCA and so if you knock out both back
one and mat - it's lethal and they found
a genetic interaction between GM c1 the
putative shock road and map 2 which is
the second type of mining
that space so when I saw this result I
said yes we have to test whether this is
the client protein all right so just the
Smith I am you know peptidase if you
don't know this is a protein that
Cleaves the initiator my thiamine off
nascent polypeptides as they're coming
off how the ribosome it's a very
important reaction all right so the
first so the hypothesis is that members
of this particular subfamily in
eukaryotes Oh metallo chaperones needed
for the biogenesis of type one but
finding mia peptidase and this function
becomes essential during the
implementation so we can design in a
genetic experiment where the bottle is
is that under zinc replete conditions
there's plenty of zinc to go around map
one is methylated no problem under zinc
limited conditions however perhaps map
one is no longer competitive enough to
interact with this labile is a cool but
the model is is that this this putative
chaperone is able to interact with this
pool fine zinc and then in the GTP
dependent manner actually transfer the
zinc to that one so what we can do is we
can knock out the chaperone and we would
expect that under zinc replete
conditions the still doesn't really care
but under zinc limited conditions the
cell is probably unhappy but you have to
remember there's this type ii there's a
little bit of functional overlap between
type 1 and type 2 so the cells probably
aren't that upset with the lack of the
chaperone
but if we knock out mat 2 then the cells
are probably really unhappy under zinc
limitation alright so i decided to do
these experiments in sacrum IC
cerevisiae
because it's a wonderful organism it
only has one of these called w like
proteins and only has one mac-11 map to
so the genetics are very straightforward
and you just look at sacrifices and
genes just pop out it's great so here
I'm looking at Y P D which is a rich
undefined medium this is looking at GM
c1 mat to this is wall type both genes
present just GMC one knocked out just
map to knocked out and this is the
double mutant with those knocked out and
then here I'm adding increasing
concentration
EDTA and so what I see is that right
away just knocking out GMC one does lead
to an idiot a sense of the phenotype
that is exacerbated if we also have not
to not doubt
I've also this is looking at a defined
medium where what I'm doing here is
these are the same mutants except I'm
also bringing back the putative shokran
on a vector to see if I can rescue the
phenotype with the gene and trans this
here is an empty vector and so what we
see here is if we would reduce the
amount of zinc in this defined medium we
see a little bit of a growth defect with
GMC one that's rescued but we see a
pretty drastic birth defect under load Z
concentrations if both Tim c1 and Matt
two are not down so this would suggest
that GMC one loss does lead to an eight
ETA since the phenotype I think it's
being specific
that's exacerbated by the loss of not
two but the real key here is this is
phenotypes this is genetics which that's
my brain automatically goes let's test
this with genetics but there's a lot
that could be going on to explain those
phenotypes so we need direct evidence
between the shock road and the putative
client so I designed an experiment that
this is how it works we have map one if
it's not loaded with metal it's not
active
we can then preload the gtp ace with
metal we can then mix them together
probably nothing's going to happen but
if we add gtp then we see transfer of
the metal and we should be able to see
map one activity all right and so as
some controls as published yes we see
metal dependent activity of map one no
metal here we can load it with various
metals and see activity the gtp ace from
yeast again this is pretty typical of
the bacterial homologues that has kind
of low intrinsic gtps activity that's
stimulated with various divalent metal
ions so this is our metal transfer a say
we we purify these proteins we remove
them of all metals
we then preload the chaperone with metal
and then we combine the two proteins and
here we're asking the Matheny music of
today's activity so this is just the
Messiah Amina peptidase by itself
activity you can add the chaperone
without pre-loaded metal the activity
but if you add the met the chaperone
pre-loaded here zinc nickel manganese
doesn't really seem to matter in vitro
we see activity of mat one this is the
gtp we can also add what's considered a
non-hydrolyzable or slow hydrolyzable
GTP analog and we see no evidence of
transfer in this case and then what was
exciting is as we were finishing up
these experiments John Hellmann's group
published this paper on zag a and
bacillus uglies we're in their case
which is probably really dependent on
the client that it's interacting with
that it can actually hydrolyze gtp so we
tested that in our system and we do see
some hydrolysis of ztp but when we do
the middle transfer assays ETP is not
able to catalyze metal transfer for our
protein at all so in conclusion we think
that the yeast GMC one can transfer
metal in vitro and that this activity is
dependent on hydrolysis of gtp and I
think what's also interesting is this
starts to suggest some hypotheses about
the mechanism of metal transfer and so
what I think is that the gtp ace is
switching between a high affinity metal
binding site and a low affinity metal
binding site and that's what enables
metal transfer alright so what about the
chloroplast so what's interesting is
these in plants and algae these are
cytosol at combi logs i'm i hypothesize
that all of these are interacting with
the cytosol ik by finding mina peptidase
this clade down here it's only found in
eukaryotes with chloroplasts and so and
what's interesting is that this protein
does localize to the floor class in arab
analysis it ought more than that is
actually found in the large molecular
weight complex in the stroma with mat 1p
which is the core class localized
methane
peptidase and something I was really
surprised to see is that I went to added
which is a gene expression database and
the top co-expressed gene um with my
chloroplast localized GTP ace is math 1b
which again is the core classifying
interface and so we've actually tested
this and sure enough we see that the
chloroplasts we don't kind GMC two can
transfer metal to the chloroplast
Matheny in the appendix so this is our
model like I said um we are thinking
that it's it has a high affinity metal
site they can interact they actually
grab zinc from the zinc depleted pool
gtp hydrolysis allows switching to like
a low affinity metal site which enables
um zinc transfer of course we need more
experiments all the experiments we've
done so far
do not do not tell us which metal is
actually being transferred because at
least in vitro there doesn't seem to be
any specificity and so we're working on
a say in the actual activity in cells
and then also we have a collaboration to
work out the different metal binding
affinities in the high affinity form and
the low acidity form and with that um
think my various funding agencies right
now Department of Energy previously NIH
for the copper chaperone my postdoc
Miriam who's been doing all the metal
transfer ace work and Qumran who is the
crystallographer inner group for the
hand binding protein and with that I'm
happy to take any questions yeah so
we've done those experiments when we've
used ascorbate we haven't used like a
reductase who just yeah and yeah so if
if the domain is fused to this oxidase
like domain it does look like it's a
heme degradation project we do not know
the product all I know is that
tivity looks like it's very similar to
huggsy so even though the domains are
switched the activity is pretty similar
I don't know what the domain I mean what
the product is which is really
interesting because this protein
localizes to the chloroplasts and
villains are involved in retrograde
signaling there's all kinds of fun and
wonderful stuff there so yeah that's a
whole avenue of research that we're just
not getting into that's you know I'm you
know a completely new heme degradation
protein in plants I'm just behind pink
I'm just wondering you know I don't know
what this what are you thoughts about
how chaperones and a whole bunch of
different mental ligands in a Cell do
coexist and with respect of metal
transfer to transporters and then versus
short distance transfer and transport
and long distance transfer function mean
histidine with the tsiyon yeah yeah like
how it all happens I mean yeah so the
question is is that because so this is
actually a really good question because
I think a lot of times in the metal
fields we study each metal in its own
box so we study copper and then this lab
of here studies zinc and this lab up
here studies iron and we only ever think
of one metal at a time and we're not
thinking too much about speciation and
what it's bound to so the question is
but in in real life all of this is
happening at the same time you have all
the metals together you have lots of
difference you know ligands and then in
plants it's complicated by I'm focusing
really on once metals are in the cell
but in plants we have we have root to
shoot transfer there's all kinds of
really fascinating things going on and
how does the cell organize all of that
when you have everything going on yeah I
mean I guess I don't know yeah I mean I
know at least in the case like because
the other tricky thing is a lot of the
divalent
cations especially in plants are
transported by divalent metal
transporters which it looks like do not
have selectivity from one ion versus
another there's some selectivity with
copper and that copper can be reduced to
copper one and so transport by CTR at
least is very specific to copper one so
I don't have an answer for route to
shoot transfer but at least once copper
is at CTR and comes into the cell you
could have a selectivity that's mediated
by protein protein interactions because
you have a transporter you have a
chaperon that's like literally
delivering it to where it needs to go
you know but I don't think people really
know yeah that's complex ation of the
design and take place in the thylakoid
lumen yeah so it takes so is there any
effect of light news pH the pH change on
the complex ation oh I don't know yeah I
don't know and we cuz there's kind of an
open question right now so my I didn't
get into this but the copper chaperone
that I worked on it looks like because
of the orientation of the ATPase it
looks like my copper chaperone is
delivering copper to within the inner
envelope space so we have copper coming
in I don't know somehow the copper
sheffrin delivers it to the ATPase we
don't know how copper
passes the stroma that's an open
question then copper is being
transported by this ATPase in the lumen
there's I've seen some some at
conferences I've seen some suggestion
that fast assign in maybe docks with the
ATP a so there's direct ligand transfer
from the ATPase to plastocyanin but
whether it yeah affects on P aged yeah I
don't know the answer to that this
anyone looked at the Zion it was just
because it's produced and I was like I
was like the chelate as a as a possible
yeah shuttle yeah
I don't know yeah so pa1 you are they
yes so when the duplication occurred
when the separation occurred of the meta
binding domain from the Pierre was how
does it ensure that it goes into this
form ah yeah so okay yes I didn't talk
about so yeah so so so there's
definitely the signal peptide is is
retained after you have the duplication
and it's really clear because PA one and
not so PA one and the chaperone but not
PA two they have a signal peptide that's
followed by glycine rich stretch and we
think that that glycine rich stretch is
what localizes it to the inner envelope
so it's kind of like a stop transfer and
so whenever we see duplication of the
chaperone it maintains the signal
peptide and the sky senior it stretch
and what's interesting is that in the
grasses there's been further duplication
of the chakra so it's like once the
chaperone had its own gene then the
plants were like oh you know every time
there was a duplication they kept the
duplicate but in those cases it lost
that glycine rich stretch so perhaps
that's neo functionalization of copper
chaperones but they're not going to the
same localization as the chloroplast
specific copper chakra yeah but how if
whether the copper chaperone just exists
in the inner envelope space and copper
gets across the outer envelope who knows
maybe it's just bound to glutathione why
you it's a it's a big open question yeah
let's go here and then we'll go with us
yeah yeah so do you think the metal and
whether the men whether the metal
binding can help the chaperone activity
what do you what do you mean like you
know I I just wondered holes are some
shop the metal that means oh yeah
I don't know how what effect whether
there's a pool of metal chaperones or
just in a neighbor form that are waiting
for metals or how dynamic that is I
don't know the answer - yeah I mean for
some of these a lot of these especially
for like zinc and copper there's
cysteine-rich so there's a whole nother
question about because you can get
disulfide you know bonds between the
system and like how that affects the
regulation of these metal chaperones
because if the metals bound those
systems are protected from oxidation so
that's a whole nother yeah
can of worms get flowers to several
other proteins or is it like specific to
one protein are they like chaperones for
whole is great question
the answer is I don't know the second
answer is I think so I maybe it's not
the case for all of them but I think
probably for some some of them I don't
think it's unreasonable to think that
they could have multiple clients but
then it becomes a question of if you
have one client and you can mediate
metal transfer based on very specific
protein protein interaction then that's
that's a mechanism for ensuring that
your only trigger of transferring metal
to the right protein if you if it was
kind of a transfer ace that can interact
with a lot of different proteins then
the question becomes well how does it
become selective and specific for all of
those proteins but not all these other
proteins like to my mind it seems like
it'd be a lot simpler to evolve a
function that's specific between the
transferase and one protein but I don't
think there's any evidence that rules
out that it could be a more general
function yeah
yes thanks for your clear presentation
I'm interested in your the second story
cos we sir are in general and patient is
a pretty dogs my village downstairs
it is ethics yes yes and you just like
us as patients the FASTA by using the
comparative genomics
yes the reconstruct has a gene family
jeiza involve the ways is a link or any
bonding so my question is quite possible
to has the older jeans went my way just
that you loser yeah oh gee apologies no
no no experimental no bench work if we
have enough computer computing resource
how it has all the key functions and
improve and basically you know so it
depends on how much information you have
about the experimentally determined
enzyme so for instance with the oxidase
that's been characterized to be involved
in b6 by synthesis if you know the
catalytic residues that are important
for that reaction you can you can ask
are those residues conserved and like
other members of the family and you have
a fairly confident hypothesis the
basement conservation of those specific
amino acids that that by chemical
reaction that function is conserved or
not conserved because if those catalytic
residues aren't there then it probably
doesn't have the same catalytic function
yes you can do that the problem is is
that in a lot of the proteins where we
know the function especially enzymes we
don't have that level of information
these are the catalytic residues that
form that function so the problem we run
into right now is we're looking at the
sequence similarity across the whole
protein and so there's issues there one
is that you can have two proteins that
have 95% sequence similarity one amino
acid has changed and now it binds a
different substrate or has a different
function okay or you have two proteins
that you probably can't even tell they
have sequence similarity if you just do
a pairwise alignment and they have the
exact same function so that's kind of
what we're dealing with when it comes to
biology is you can have either or and we
just don't know I mean yes we right
right now so if you look at the
statistics about 99.95% of proteins and
our databases are not characterized are
not associated with experimental data
okay that's way too many
I mean that's like millions and millions
and millions proteins we're never going
to experiment
characterized everything I'm not gonna
do it so we do need computational tools
but you know how do you get from there
to there I mean yeah yeah there's just I
mean with more of a file of genomic
contextualizing type of proach you can
at least kind of say okay this is the
function and maybe I'm moving more
towards that's not the function or maybe
I'm moving more towards that is the
function and then if it's important to
you test it this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu